die uniklinik essen alltag auf der
station
wie in allen krankenhäusern deutschlands
arbeitet das personal unter hochdruck
währenddessen ein gebäude weiter fünf
neue pflegekräfte werden heute von silke
langer vom internationalen
bewerbermanagement begrüßt sie kommen
aus serbien und sollen das team ab
sofort verstärken
hinter ihnen liegen anstrengende monate
deutsch lernen dokumente beglaubigen
lassen abschied nehmen
ich komme weil ich machte mich dann zu
weit
der erste schritt ist geschafft ab jetzt
arbeiten sie in einem deutschen
krankenhaus und versorgen patienten in
einer ihnen fremden sprache die 30
jährige maria aus serbien fängt heute
auf der neurologie an vanessa rohde ist
ab heute matthias erste
ansprechpartnerin
das ist wichtig denn die vielen neuen
eindrücke müssen erstmal verarbeitet
werden
das ist wichtig ist dass wir wissen dass
immer jemand da ist wenn sie fragen
können ihr hier den alltag auf unsere
neurologischen station näher zu bringen
den kollegen vorzustellen und sie ihr zu
helfen dieses teams zu integrieren
an der uniklinik essen arbeiten gut 3000
pflegekräfte 46 davon wurden im ausland
angeworben knapp 70 werden dieses jahr
noch erwartet ich treffe
pflegedirektorin andrea schmidt rumpus
sie erklärt mir warum die ausländischen
pflegekräfte so dringend gebraucht
werden
wieso sind sie überhaupt dazu
übergegangen pflegekräfte auch aus dem
ausland zu rekrutieren deutschland über
altert das ist bekannt deutschlandweit
und wir haben als einen baustein der
personalakquise die internationale
pflege bei uns mit wir sehen ansonsten
gucken wir auch dass wir auf eigene
ausbildung setzen und den part auch sehr
stärken aber der wären es ohne die
internationale pflege nicht schaffen
bundesweit ist die suche nach
pflegepersonal ein riesiges problem
allein 2020 blieben im schnitt rund
36.000 stellen in der pflege unbesetzt
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen fördert
deshalb die anwerbung von pflegekräften
aus dem ausland
der bedarf ist so groß dass wir ohne
fachkräfte aus dem ausland ihn nicht
werden decken können
die anzahl ausländischer pflegekräfte
ist in den letzten jahren rasant
gestiegen
2013 waren es noch rund 74.000
beschäftigte ohne deutschen pass 2020
mit 208.000 fast dreimal so viele
mehr als die hälfte kommt dabei
inzwischen aus ländern außerhalb der eu
wie bosnien serbien oder den philippinen
aber auch aus lateinamerika die
anwerbung läuft zum großteil über
private personalvermittlung agenturen
[Musik]
wie viel investieren sie sollen die
rekrutierungen von einer pflegekraft
das ist von agentur zur natur ganz
unterschiedlich die kosten sind zwischen
neun und 21.000 euro je nachdem wieviel
serviceangebot mit dabei ist
unterstützung beim umzug unterstützung
bei den behördengängen also es variiert
stark ich recherchiere im netz nach
vermittlungsagenturen für den deutschen
pflegemarkt das angebot scheint
unendlich die versprechungen sind groß
tolles gehalt und viel urlaub für die
pflegekräfte dinge die wohl kein
deutscher mit dem pflege büro verbindet
ich nehme kontakt zu einer agentur auf
und gebe mich als mexikanische
krankenpflegerin aus
hallo wie kann ich als pflegekraft nach
deutschland kommen
hallo guten tag bist du schon
ausgebildete krankenschwester ja aber
ich habe keine arbeit gerade mach dir
keine sorgen
deutschland hat arbeit für dich
innerhalb von 10 monaten lässt sich das
regeln
auf die frage wie viel ich verdiene
bekomme ich keine antwort aber mir wird
versichert das sind ganz tolle
arbeitgeber ganz ehrlich es wird dir
sehr gefallen klingt fast zu schön um
wahr zu sein
denn nicht immer läuft es wie von den
agenturen versprochen in köln bin ich
mit der deutsch lehrerin maria esch
verabredet sie führt mich zu einer ihrer
schülerinnen die junge frau kommt aus
sao paulo brasilien kurz nach dem
interview bittet sie uns ihr gesicht
unkenntlich zu machen so groß ist ihre
angst vor repressalien
die brasilianerin hat die lehrerin
kennengelernt weil sie hilfe beim
deutschlernen brauchte ohne ihre
unterstützung wäre die junge frau
wahrscheinlich längst wieder zurück in
ihre heimat
denn statt einer besseren zukunft
erlebte sie ihren persönlichen albtraum
das versprechen wahr dass ich nach
deutschland kommen könnte um hier zu
arbeiten in einem bereich in dem ich
schon in brasilien gearbeitet habe für
den ich die entsprechende erfahrung
mitbrachte und dass sie mir bei der
gesamten integration mit dem krankenhaus
sowie bei den bürokratischen problemen
helfen würden doch in deutschland
angekommen arbeitet die brasilianerin
weder in ihrem fachbereich noch in der
klinik die man ihr im vorhinein genannt
hatte auch sprachlich hat sie große
defizite medizinisches vokabular für den
pflegeberuf hat sie im kurs der agentur
nicht gelernt sie zeigt mir den
vermittlungsvertrag wussten sie worauf
sie sich einlassen als sie diesen
vertrag unterschrieben haben
nein da ich keine idee hatte wie das
krankenpflege system in deutschland
funktioniert und auch nicht wie die
agentur mit der angelegenheit umgehen
würde
in der klinik in deutschland gibt es
anders als versprochen niemanden der sie
ein arbeitet ruhezeiten und urlaubs
absprachen werden nicht eingehalten und
neben dem vollzeitjob
doch der druck des deutsch lernen die
junge frau verfällt in eine schwere
depression
sie verlässt die klinik doch dann das
böse erwachen die agentur fordert geld
denn laut vertrag hätte die
brasilianerin 36 monate beim selben
arbeitgeber bleiben müssen ist dass der
betrag den die agentur jetzt noch von
ihnen verlangt fast 5000 euro
du bist stark was bedeutet diese vertrag
für sie erst ein gefängnis weil ich an
einem ort arbeiten muss an dem ich nicht
glücklich bin und ich kann da nicht weg
weil ich dann eine strafe zahlen
so ihr empfinden stadt ein besseres
leben zu haben geht es ihr schlechter
als je zuvor ist dieser fall eine
ausnahme
ich recherchiere und tatsächlich melden
sich weitere pflegekräfte mit ähnlichen
vermittlungs verträgen in allen die mir
vorliegen finden sich bindungs klauseln
und strafzahlungen
rechtlich sind viele dieser klauseln
unwirksam haben solche verträge methode
in dortmund gibt es eine beratungsstelle
bei der ausländische pflegekräfte hilfe
finden
faire integration ich spreche mit
beratungs referentin christiane tendenz
inwiefern sind das einzelfälle mit denen
wir es hier zu tun haben ich glaube
jeder fall ist unterschiedlich
tatsächlich aber das ist einzelfälle
sind kann man auch nicht wirklich sagen
weil sie kommen ja alle in dem fall über
anwerbe organisationen die kommen nicht
über staatliche stellen oder so das
problem ist halt tatsächlich dass die
diese anwerber organisation nicht
reguliert sind also jeder kann eine
anwerbe organisation aufmachen und es
gebe viele fragwürdige agenturen auf dem
markt ich zeige ihr die vermittlungs
verträge aus meiner recherche die
inhalte sind teilweise widersprüchlich
so heißt es die vermittlung seife den
kandidaten kostenfrei
der sprachkurs kostenlos doch ein paar
paragrafen später bei erfolgreicher
teilnahme und arbeitsbeginn laut vertrag
ist der kurs für den kandidaten
kostenfrei
die stadt unterstützung zu leisten
fordern die vermittler im schlimmsten
fall geld von den pflegekräften die hoch
verschuldet sind denn manchmal eine zahl
von 23.000 euro beispielsweise also es
ist schon so eine menge geld und die
leute können das wahrscheinlich nie in
ihrem leben abbezahlen
auch wenn die verträge vor gericht
wahrscheinlich keinen bestand hätten
wären sich nur wenige
viele der betroffenen sind schon
verschuldet bevor sie es überhaupt nach
deutschland geschafft haben
sao paulo die größte stadt brasiliens
hier lebt ja nie barreto die 39 jährige
sollte im märz als pflegekraft in
deutschland beginnen anfang 2020
unterschreibt sie einen vertrag mit
einer vermittlungsagentur kurz darauf
einen arbeitsvertrag mit einem deutschen
krankenhaus aufgrund der pandemie
spreche ich mit jan über video
die annie fängt im mai 2020 mit dem
online deutschkurs der
vermittlungsagentur an
es ist das erste mal dass sie eine
fremdsprache lernt auch als wir mit dem
deutschkurs angefangen haben haben sie
gesagt dass wir uns zu 100 prozent auf
den sprachkurs konzentrieren müssen und
dass wir unsere jobs aufgeben sollen
nicht nur ich meine kollegen haben das
gleiche gemacht wie annie fühlt sich
sicher durch den bereits
unterschriebenen arbeitsvertrag mit der
deutschen klinik und gibt ihren job als
krankenpflegerin in sao paulo auf um
sich voll und ganz auf deutsch lernen zu
konzentrieren
sie wollte für sich und ihre fünf kinder
ein besseres leben
ich habe das flugticket gekauft
versicherung alles weil sie uns gesagt
haben dass wir es kaufen sollen die
agentur hat uns gesagt dass wir das von
unserem eigenen geld bezahlen sollen
oder dass sie uns den betrag leihen
würden dann würden wir ihnen das danach
zurückzahlen können sie ungefähr sagen
wie viel sie jetzt schon in den traum
vom leben und arbeiten in deutschland
investiert haben ungefähr 7000 fast 1200
euro knapp zwei monatsgehälter für die
brasilianerin
anfang märz hatten wir die deutsch test
und es war alles sehr gehetzt
im lesen schreiben und hören habe ich
bestanden im sprechen allerdings haben
wir ein paar punkte gefehlt
also habe ich den test noch einmal
gemacht und sie sagten ich hätte wieder
nicht bestanden nachdem ciani den test
zweimal nicht bestanden hat fliegt sie
aus dem programm
obwohl im vertrag nichts davon steht wie
oft sie den test wiederholen darf möchte
sie hier nach nun mehrere tausend euro
zahlen wie viel geld verlangt die
agenturen jetzt noch von ihnen ihre
sekretärin hat mich zu einem gespräch
gebeten da sagte sie dass ich den betrag
der im vertrag steht zahlen muss das
sind 3700 euro
seit ihrer kündigung hat sie keinen
neuen job mehr als krankenpflegerin
gefunden und dann meldet sich noch eine
brasilianische krankenschwester bei mir
patrizia cavalli aus rio de janeiro sie
sollte mit derselben agentur vianney
nach deutschland kommen
doch auch sie hat es nie hierher
geschafft was habe ich gemacht ich habe
meine wohnung verkauft und direkt
nachdem ich die wohnung verkauft hatte
noch in derselben woche hat mich die
chefin des kurses aus dem programm
genommen
trotz arbeitsvertrag und auch den flug
hatte ich schon bezahlt
patrizia hat ihre ganze existenz
aufgegeben um nach deutschland zu kommen
jetzt steht sie ohne arbeit und ohne
wohnung dar und muss sich und ihren 13
jährigen sohn irgendwie über die runden
bringen
ich wünsche mir dass niemand in die
falle tappt in die ich getappt bin es
ist für niemanden gut ich wünsche dass
nicht mal meinem schlimmsten feind
es melden sich weitere pflegekräfte bei
mir auch von anderen agenturen
sebastianer all dies die fred ist die
einzige die bereit ist offen mit mir zu
sprechen sie glaubt ohnehin nichts mehr
verlieren zu können
auch sie wurde offenbar mit großen
versprechungen auf ein besseres leben in
deutschland gelockt
es war ein traumhaftes angebot
sie haben mir eine arbeit mit einem
tollen gehalt versprochen
vor allem für brasilianische
verhältnisse im oktober 2009 10
unterschreibt sie den
vermittlungsvertrag mit einer agentur
und ab dann das war der beginn der hölle
meines lebens weil entschuldigung es ist
sehr hart darüber zu sprechen
auch sebastian erzählt dass sie alles
aufgegeben hat sie ist nach sao paulo
gezogen um den sprachkurs der agentur zu
besuchen
am ende konnte sie nicht mal mehr ihren
lebensunterhalt finanzieren
sie bricht den kurs ab und soll nun viel
geld bezahlen
sie wollen 5000 euro
können sie das bezahlen auf keinen fall
ich habe ja nicht mal eine arbeit wie
soll ich das bezahlen in berlin habe ich
einen termin mit der geschäftsführerin
des arbeitgeberverbands pflege isabel
halles auch sie bestätigt auf dem
rekrutierungs markt laufe etwas schief
sie setzt sich mit ihrer
bundesarbeitsgemeinschaft ausländische
pflegekräfte seit jahren für mehr
transparenz und qualität im
vermittlungsgeschäft ein moderner
menschenhandel teilweise weil sie dann
von dem personalmangel den wir dann in
den gesundheitseinrichtungen hier in
deutschland haben einfach den profit
schlagen und ihn mit falschen
versprechungen dort in den drittländern
oben personal auch werben
wieso gibt es denn so viele dubiose
agenturen die schwierigkeit einfach dass
wir keine gesetzlichen vorgaben haben
wer darf denn als vermittler überhaupt
arbeiten in deutschland
wir haben auch vermittlungsunternehmen
die einen nicht deutschen sitzen
uns fehlt einfach eine
registrierungsstelle
wo man sich informieren kann wer ist in
dem geschäft überhaupt aktiv und es
fehlen wie gesagt rahmenbedingungen wo
man dann weiß das sind seriöse
vermittler wie viele agenturen es
überhaupt auf dem markt gibt kann mir
niemand sagen was tut die politik gegen
das problem des unregulierten agentur
marktes zumindest existiert ein
staatliches programm zur anwerbung von
ausländischen pflegekräften das ohne
private vermittler auskommt triple win
seit 2013 hat die agentur für arbeit mit
der deutschen gesellschaft für
internationale zusammenarbeit darüber
bisher 4425 pflegekräfte nach
deutschland geholt
zu wenig bei über 36.000 offenen stellen
deshalb will bundesgesundheitsminister
jens spahn auch den privaten
vermittlungs markt fördern
er reist 2009/10 bis nach mexiko um dort
für unser gesundheitssystem zu werben
es geht ja darum vor allem auch ist den
agenturen die die anwerbung machen
leichter zu machen schnellere
visaverfahren schnellere
anerkennungsverfahren der abschlüsse in
deutschland um genau diese verfahren für
die agenturen zu beschleunigen wird die
defa die deutsche fachkräfte agentur für
gesundheits- und pflegeberufe gegründet
sie soll die bürokratischen prozesse
rund um die anwerbung binden
wir haben mit der gründung der agentur
der deutschen fachkräfte agentur für
gesundheits- und pflegeberufe wirklich
ein meilenstein entwicklung in
deutschland erreicht die meilenstein
entwicklung ist bisher jedoch
ausgeblieben
auf nachfrage teilt uns die defa mit
seit anfang 2020 seien gerade einmal ca
40 fälle abgeschlossen nur wenige
agenturen scheinen die defa also
überhaupt zu nutzen
die bundesregierung hat immerhin 2,3
millionen euro in dieses projekt
gesteckt
um für mehr transparenz und fairere
vermittlungs bedingungen zu sorgen hat
die politik die entwicklung eines
gütesiegels beschlossen doch das soll
freiwillig bleiben
warum schafft das
bundesgesundheitsministerium keine
rechtlich verbindlichen standards und
regelungen sondern lediglich ein
freiwilliges gütesiegeln man teilt uns
mit der gesetzgeber hat dies
ausdrücklich so vorgesehen das
bundesministerium bereitet anreize für
unternehmen vor unter dem dach des
gütesiegels anzuwerben
doch ob ein freiwilliges siegel wirklich
etwas verändern kann
solange die nationale politik keine
verbindlichen regelungen für den
agenturmarkt schafft können ausländische
pflegekräfte nur hoffen dass sich alle
so genau anschauen mit wem sie
zusammenarbeiten wie die uniklinik essen
ich spreche noch einmal mit
pflegedirektorin andrea schmidt rumpus
vertragsentwurf von einer agentur wir
haben uns sehr intensiv und sehr lange
mit den agenturen persönlicher
verabredet und ermögliche klauseln
besprochen weil wir einfach für unsere
zusammenarbeit in gewissem rahmen auch
festlegen wollten
die ausländischen pflegekräfte sollen
kommen um zu bleiben
deswegen werden sie intensiv betreut
eine gute integration und unterstützung
vor ort sind das allerwichtigste
ich meine wir arbeiten da ja für und mit
menschen das darf man nicht vergessen
und das ist uns einfach wichtig dass wir
dann sauberen guten prozess haben der
pflegenotstand ist so gewaltig dass sich
ein riesiger markt für die vermittlung
von pflege fachkräften aus dem ausland
entwickelt hat doch viele der
personalagenturen wirtschaften am rande
der legalität wir sind auf ausländische
pflegekräfte angewiesen und gerade
deswegen ist es wichtig dass es klare
gesetzliche regelungen gibt und die
vermittlung fair abläuft
[Musik]